ladies and gentlemen welcome to the tim
dillon show uh excited to be with you a
lot is uh
happening and not happening
as always
um did you i saw the many saints of
newark have you seen that movie yet i
haven't seen it yet this is weird
and i i i i don't want to talk about
this because i don't want people to get
the wrong idea i know that a lot of
people are they have a you know
obviously i love joey diaz who's in the
movie
and i love a lot of um
the people that are that are in the
movie right i mean the sopranos is an
epic show i don't
it's weird the direction they took
to me
i think it's odd
um it's strange to me
to
do a prequel
where a huge element of the character
that was not at all in the
show is brought out
that's weird to me the prequel
uh to the many states of newark is about
how tony soprano like got into the mafia
and
the entire movie
i don't know if you know this
but is literally and this is a little
[ __ ]
why he was smiling
the entire movie
is tony
getting into the mafia
because he's gay
and he's trying to hide his sexuality
from
other people and he feels the most
effective way to do that
and
there are sex scenes
where tony
soprano is having sex with men in this
movie
as the receptive partner he's taking it
in the movie and
people were shocked at this the whole
crux of the movie
is that tony's in an interracial
interracial relationship in newark with
a man
this is odd
to me because in the sopranos there was
never
a thought
that ah listen i'm a gay guy i think gay
cinema is great but there was never a
thought that tony was gay
so to me to make
his character gay
and give him this the story arc of
having a love interest
is very very strange and even if you did
all of that
the
visceral nature of a lot of these sex
scenes i mean it's
really aggressive
it's aggressive
but this is what hollywood has decided
to do
and i'm i'm emailing you right there's a
scene
because you know that i was asked to
audition for this oh you did i was asked
to audition for this so i got the script
and
there is a scene that me and you are
going to read
from the many saints of newark okay and
i again i worry
i worry that
you know again i don't want to offend
anyone that really enjoyed the picture
but i think
that it's worth stating how different
this is
than most of what
we've come to expect
from the david chase
and the sopranos do you have it did you
get it i'm refreshing
there it goes
okay so
we're this is a scene
from the many saints of newark and again
i'm
so here don't read it read it as you do
it that's what a real actor does
okay okay who am i
you're african-american man
now i want you to start
i want you to start
describe the scene up top
okay you want me to be the narrator yes
okay
tony a young sexually confused man
explores gender and sexuality with older
men in the mafia this is weird
right
i mean let's be honest is this
is this not
is this not weird
this is not
what i thought the movie was gonna be
about and listen i don't do a good tony
soprano impression that's not what i'm
trying to do here
what i'm trying to do is act and breathe
life into the scene okay so let's start
okay tony is sitting on a is sitting on
a bench by the basketball court he
notices a young african-american man
playing basketball shirtless tony is shy
at first but brings to speak to him
well that i don't know why that was
written like that
hey what are you doing
okay so i'm african-american right
you're the man
this is tony's at a basketball court
yeah
he's watching an african-american man
play basketball shirtless and tony is
sitting there and i think in the movie
he's eating an ice cream cone
seductively
but
that was added
later
again this is the many saints of newark
okay this is true all right i i'm only
laughing because
i'm
stunned that they went in this direction
okay tony is tried first but speaks to
him hey what are you doing i'm playing
ball what are you doing watching you
watching you like what you say hey what
you're doing right now with the the
black hands and stuff
it's not necessary okay you know what i
mean do you know what you just did
you're like i'm playing ball black
people don't talk like that okay do you
see what you did when you were like in
the 70s i'm trying to think of how
they'd play it maybe
it's groovy i think you're just just
really just respect the work okay
okay i don't think we need to start
doing a dance okay okay hey what are you
doing i'm playing ball what are you
doing watching you like what you see
okay it's
i'm playing ball what are you doing
watching you like what you see watching
you like what you see yeah
maybe i do
let me ask you something
do yous have bigger dicks than us
you know like that's what people say
only one way to find out
you guys must have real brazil's over
there where you come from i'm italian
i'm in the mafia or at least i will be
but i can't tell anyone that i'm you
know into men
i know what that's like you do
my pastor says that gay people go to
hell he calls them three dollar bills
your church that's what they do to
screaming at everything hey you think
anyone is there right now
maybe we could go over there
you want to see my church i want to see
you
tony pulls a man close to him and they
begin making out tony is grabbing his
crotch the man seems uncomfortable with
all the people around
not here we can have sex in my church
so this is
crazy to me then they go have sex in a
church
where tony is getting it in the ass
and it's crazy so is there like a gospel
choir and everything but they're in the
back no it's an empty church okay and
he's just like pounding tony
and then tony says i don't know if i
want you just this is a quote for the
movie tony goes i don't know if i want
you to explode in me but i i also want
to taste you
and then the guy goes
well have you heard of fel ching and
tony goes no what's that and the guy
goes that's where i would come inside of
you and then suck it out with a straw or
something and then spit it back in your
mouth all i'm saying is this is very
surprising to me
that's what i'm saying
again go see the film make your own
decisions
it's very surprising that they went in
this direction personally
you know
i mean the whole thing
when we meet carmella
like it's crazy because he's like having
sex with guys is weird
anyway
that's just putting it that's just my
two cents
i don't want to make anyone mad no and
joey diaz is in this i heard it james
damore got mad at me that guy you know
that guy from google yeah who got he's
kind of has marfan syndrome i think he's
like he's really like i don't know he's
like very lanky
and he uh he's autistic he says he's
autistic he says that he sees the world
differently he got angry with me because
i criticized his digital art and this is
the guy that wrote the memo um at google
he wrote a memo where he was basically
like i think women should have bags
around their heads and get taken out
into the parking lot
and
he said that there's you know whatever
so he made this ai art it's very bad so
i just wrote these are all bad i quote
tweeted it and then he used that video
that that thing of me where i have a
sunburn and he goes
ai is a matter of inputs like for this
foul one all i put was gay chris farley
i and i have a horrible sunburn i never
should have put that photo out but
sometimes you got to put a photo out
where you look the worst yeah yeah so
that it can always be the photo people
use but again that photo still makes
more sense than his like kind of deeply
satanic very strange ai art
that he did
it's a god
it's like demons and hell and so i don't
know what the inputs he put in but again
people get very sensitive all these a
lot of these tech pros which weird
they're like kind of like goth
theater
blanks
and i don't know what even though
they're like tech bros they're like i
don't you know what i mean they're like
weird nerd and again they got me he was
angry at me
um
and i defended him when he wrote that
memo saying that women wanted to get
bags over their heads and take it out
into the parking lot at google
so i don't understand what's the problem
but he's very sensitive these people are
very sensitive okay and he lives in
austin so we know he's one of the worst
people in the world
but we still support him that and we
don't think it's fair that he was fired
from google for saying that women like
to have garbage bags put over them and
then put in a van
um he got angry with me the people don't
like objective reality anymore when you
say like like the way he says like men
and women have different they have
different aptitudes it's also like some
things are bad that ai is art is bad bad
that little nas x version of jolene is
bad
it's not good he's speaking he's going
jolene
and of course dolly parton got a tweet
like i just am honored and i love him
and
because you can't be honest because the
appeal of little nogs
little nasa
is in the package it's in
there's a good-looking black gay guy and
he has
uh you know he's a flare about him he
knows what he's doing but the the actual
vocals are
not good and for anyone to pretend
they're good then the old town road song
was kind of a troll that became huge yes
but
and he's smart but it's and he knows
what to do he says look i'm [ __ ]
satan this week and next week i'm
pregnant
but that's in that the rep that's
replacing the music right see people
should realize that that's not in
addition to the music
like lady gaga is talented and then she
does a lot of that stuff in addition to
me this is completely
like instead of the music we're gonna do
this i'm gonna uh you know take a photo
of myself or or have a cgi photo of
myself made where i have a baby
and this is like you know but again to
say like this isn't good
people are very angry or to point out
the ai art and go hey man this is not
good
it's objectively terrible i'm sure
you're a lovely person but this art is
very very bad and why are you
why do you care
you just put inputs into a computer and
then it made it why do you give a [ __ ]
maybe i'm insulting the ai
it may not be you
but you know
people don't like the truth it's
unfortunate
you know it's like a lot of people are
not gonna like to hear that tony soprano
is a gay man
but this is what it is
um
i love simply safe i'm telling you right
now you need them they launched two new
wireless outdoor security cameras that's
right simply save the system the us news
and world report says the best home
security system of 2021 just got even
better brand new outdoor security camera
is engineered with all the advanced
attack and security features you want
after the stalker incident we have them
we're all using them it's ultra wide 140
degree field of view so you can keep
watch over your entire yard it has 1080
hd resolution with an eight times zoom
that means you can zoom in and clearly
see the faces and license plates to
capture critical evidence of the people
trying to do you harm
it is a built-in spotlight with color
night vision so you can keep an eye on
what's going on day or night it's super
simple to set up and usually takes only
minutes it has an easy to remove
rechargeable battery key
so it doesn't need an outlet you can go
anywhere on your property this camera
has it all and integrates with your
simply safe home security system
extending the protection to the outside
together it means every door window and
room are protected and now your property
will be too
to learn more about this exciting new
simply safe wireless outdoor security
camera visit simplysafe.com
tim dillon what's more simply save is
celebrating this new camera by offering
off your entire new system and your
first month of monitoring service free
when you enroll in interactive
monitoring again that's simplysafe.com
tim dillon i'm so excited about this
because it is important to be safe
especially now especially now a lot of
americans are on a high deductible
health insurance plan on the hook for
thousands of dollars of deductibles
co-pays sky-high premiums there is
something called crowd health i i really
want everyone to check this out it's a
better way to pay medical expenses you
know the government unfortunately is not
getting their act together so we're
going to need to look out for ourselves
crowdheld there's a community of people
who are tired of paying for a broken
system a place where you can get a
simple flexible and affordable way to
pay for your health care being in the
crowd health community can save hundreds
of dollars monthly and put thousands of
dollars in your pocket membership is a
monthly subscription start or stop when
it's convenient for you simple and
transparent pricing customized to fit
your needs crowd health lowers your
monthly health care costs if it didn't
why would you even use it and you could
see any doctor you want using their app
find nearly any doctor in the country
rank from one to five stars scan bills
throw them away crowd health takes it
from there press a button or receive
virtual care anytime anywhere a
community of health conscious members
who want to get and stay healthy in
return for lower prices crowd health
gets rid of insurance middlemen and
passes the savings onto its members 100
of your monthly membership pays actual
health care costs helping the whole
crowd health community stay healthy
while keeping more money in your pocket
crowd health is able to offer amazing
prices because of its community of
health conscious members but for limited
time my listeners get their first month
free and
after you've been a member crowd health
will include a fitness wearable wow
that's 30 days to try risk-free plus the
fitness wearable just go to join
crowdhealth.com
fit and enter the code tim dillon at
sign up that's join crowdhealth.com fit
promo code t-i-m-d-i-l-l-o-n
crowd health is not health insurance
it's a community-powered alternative
terms and conditions may apply
this is something funny that you showed
me from the show what is it called the
united states of al that's correct yeah
this show uh united states have rewrite
season two premiere
to offer powerful moving reaction to
situation in afghanistan by the way the
title of that article tells you
everything you want to know and
immediately you know it was the wrong
move
rewrite season two premiere to offer
powerful moving reaction to situation in
afghanistan is this guy afghani he's
indian and he's from south africa she's
nothing to do with afghanistan he's
playing an afghani interpreter in the
show
so he was always an afghani interpreter
in the united states val
yes he was always well and his best
friend is a marine who fought in
afghanistan and now they're here and
they're you know oh well then i guess
they have to do something
but he's not afghani in real life
understood but i mean
in the show he's an afghani interpreter
i believe so yeah and his friend's a
marine you wonder if the writers got
like a tip that this was going to happen
do you think the united states of hal
knew before the state department that
the taliban was about to take over
because it does feel like the united
states eval now did have to die like i i
do feel they were in the unenviable
position of having to address it it
feels that way it feels like they had i
had no idea he was an afghani
interpreter what show is this like
why would this be a show
and so the united states of al is about
apparently an afghani interpreter
um and his marine best friend
that's right that are what buds they're
like buddies yeah they're buddies and
they live together i i think in the same
town here it is a marine combat veteran
struggling to readjust to civilian life
in ohio and then awamir aka al the
interpreter who served with this unit in
afghanistan has just arrived to start a
new life in america so it's just their
friendship so it's a it's an afghani
interpreter and a marine they come back
to the u.s hilarity ensues
now
the united states of al of course they
have to do something yes they can't
ignore it they have to do something i'm
sympathetic to this more than i thought
i would be it does seem to be the
also don't make a very bad show like
this in the first place yeah it's such a
bad show
it's a marine and an afghani interpreter
like having beers
like like the afghanistan war was worth
it
that's what the premise of the show is
it brought them together it's a
brotherhood so what a lot of people are
dead doesn't matter
that's the premise of the show this is
what hollywood likes to do they like to
like make things where they go it's kind
of a wash isn't it
i mean al and his buddy would have never
been brought together
if we didn't have the afghanistan war
so it's an odd way to
market a program but they love this [ __ ]
oh yeah this is how they kind of
smooth over all these mistakes and by
mistakes i don't mean mistakes i mean
like
you know the bloodlust
empire it means to call it a mistake you
know mistake is like where's the car
keys not like oh we're going to
afghanistan to pay off pedophiles
and you know steal lithium-ion that's
not really a mistake but the way at the
end of all that to kind of make it like
hey sorry they do these cutesy little
shows
where like people become friends with
each other from you know
this 20-year long
war
that killed people for absolutely no
reason
and uh but the united states of al
and so
this is the scene
where al i guess realizes that the
taliban
this is the promo for the upcoming
episode that's it's the big afghanistan
episode it's the big one yeah yeah this
is the one because the the fans of the
united states have i don't know who they
are i imagine they're
older white people with dementia's not
it's setting in
it's not it hasn't fully ravaged their
brain but it's setting in
and they're like we like the united
states of hell
and it's because that's cbs is crowd
they're old people
they're elderly people that watch the
united states of al and it explains to
them why we went to war in afghanistan
uh on through the tv and they sit there
and they let
mashed potatoes dribble out of their
mouths while they stare
at this so now let's play this for
everyone this is the afghanistan episode
from the united states of al
riley
is it confirmed the taliban took her out
kabul might be next al's family's there
we're at the airport hello there's so
many people i don't think i can do this
listen to me for a minute
this is
so
al's family is still in
afghanistan he's
during this scene do you like do you
quit
when they ask you to do this
when they say do you mind taking out a
phone
and then you're going to on speakerphone
pretend you're talking to someone
desperately trying to get out of
afghanistan
like at this point do you think of
choosing another career
there's always got to be a moment in
your career like i have it all the every
day every minute
but you got to imagine that when you're
doing this it's so
offensive on so many levels and
it's
first of all
when painful things happen of course one
tries to make them into art forever
right
but this is like immediately this is
happening and it's also happening in the
most grotesque
way imaginable like we're rewriting the
season premiere so that we can deliver a
powerful moving message
uh from our sitcom
on cbs play the rest of this but it's
crazy
it's crazy they're doing a scene where i
guess his family member going hide
enough i can do this
and
al is trying to talk them through it
yeah yeah okay play it from the
beginning again please and i won't
interrupt
riley
is it confirmed the taliban took her out
kabul might be next al's family's there
we're at the airport hello there's so
many people i don't think i can do this
listen to me
i am right there with you but he's not
but but hold on
but al
is in america that's right
now
could
does cbs include any of the perspective
of the taliban
in this
like does the taliban get to have any
say
at all
or is this just
some type of
like
you know propaganda vehicle for the us
because i think the taliban
have something to say as well that i
would like to see their
uh
opinion in a cbs sitcom as well
if we could fictionalize
the taliban
and what they want
out of this whole thing
well when is it on when can you watch
the united states of al i think it's
coming out sometime this week it says
the premiere's dropping really soon
because i really want to see this well
it's exciting and the the indian actors
seem to have locked his account upon the
uh
release of this promo well we it's not
the actor's fault they're saying the
words
that
they were written on the page i think
people are mad that he's indian though
and he's doing an afghani accent
they're not even mad at the they're not
even mad at the right things what they
should be mad at is that a the show
exists right b cbs exists
they're not even mad at their you know
they should uh i like that the taliban
just took her out
kabul could be next al has family there
here's a real synopsis of an episode
that came out
this year
greets riley's daughter hazel and
introduces himself as her godfather on a
video call with his mother alice berated
for wearing shorts as it against his
religion as a muslim to do
the following day alan riley go the dmv
where al becomes nervous after seeing
that his female driving instructor paula
is also wearing shorts and as a result
fails his driving test
wanting to adjust to american social
norms al talks with riley art and an
offended lizzie to sort things out
deciding to to avoid forcing his
religious double standards on other
people and his following visits to the
dnv with paula as his driving instructor
al overcomes his issues by acknowledging
both paul and himself are wearing shorts
only to become nervous once again
after stopping at a traffic light next
to a charity car wash with bikini clad
women
okay
why are we doing this
why why do we need to do this
why are we trying to do this
i'm very curious as to why
cbs is doing this
like this is a guy who's gonna have to
like some of his some of his beliefs and
and views or seem a little antiquated
and cbs is now trying to figure out like
funny situations to put him in
i i mean
who's this for
i guess this is for young
muslims that love cbs i suppose so is
that what it's about
that are also wrestling with some of
these ideas
and they need to
al goes to a party with milk and gets
nervous when the women start taking
jello shots and they're [ __ ]
he doesn't know what to do
he doesn't know how to square this with
his muslim faith
drinking tequila out of a woman's belly
button really tests his religion next
week on the united states of al
is the worst show in the world other
than la brea have you seen this thing la
brea no no it's a show where the i think
there's a sinkhole
and then three then people read the read
read the description of this a massive
sinkhole opens up in the middle of la
separating a family between two worlds
the mother and son fall into an
unexplainable
primeval land alongside a group of
strangers trying to figure out where
they are and how to get back home left
above is a daughter who barely manages
to survive the disaster and the father
whose troubled past and hallucinations
make him an unlikely choice to help
solve the mystery and reunite the family
what
but when he realizes his visions might
just be the key to finding their loved
ones time will be the only thing that
stands in their way this show is about a
hole
that opened up and people fell into it
into a world with dinosaurs this is the
biggest show on tv right now
and i know a kid in it was like a nice
kid but i do think it has to be canceled
and he has to be homeless because this
is truly a horrible horrible thing so
this is the biggest show and squid game
this show on netflix perhaps i don't
know anything about squid game but all i
know is that la brea is about people
falling in a hole and landing
in the land before time
and they're like running around fighting
like big prehistoric animals i mean look
at
the
look at the la
i mean
is there anything stupider than this
who
is working like
they don't know what to do anymore
so they're just like yeah whatever man
let's just
yeah it's a hole that opens up and
everybody falls into it and
they fight dinosaurs and the dad is
hallucinations and they unlock the key
to the mystery what's the key to the
myth we don't know
we'll figure it out in season four leave
us alone
it's embarrassing and salt bae is losing
his mind suggesting that he's becoming
an inspiration to millions of children
so bae is now saying
this is his quote now everybody wants to
be a butcher because of me now if you
ask a kid they want to be salt bae they
see me as an idol i'm an inspiration to
a lot of people in a very short period
of time
salt bae let me correct you
you're an inspiration to absolutely no
one
no child wants to be you
i've never been to salt based
restaurants
he had one viral video where he was
salting meat that was it well
we know that
but have you ever been to his restaurant
well it's these restaurants where i
guess on a good day he walks around from
table to table and he has like a
a big sword this is true
and then he just lobs women's clits off
with his sword
i mean this is
great but people like it people love it
he lobs clits of women off and he
performs clitorectomies of women eating
in the restaurant and people like it and
then he salts the
[ __ ]
i just personally yeah i think it's a
little backwards
but people like it
imagine eating in a salt bay restaurant
like unironically
going there and going like i'm excited
for this
i'm excited
the eye-popping prices of salt-based new
london restaurant included
steak and a 15 red bull well here's the
deal
i am a fan of raising the prices of food
till it becomes comical i do like that
there's something that's very fitting
about raising the prices of food so that
they become so ridiculous
and insane i remember when steaks used
to be like in the high 30s then they
were in the mid-40s for a while
now then they were in the 50s now like
they're eighty dollars
seventy two dollars for a steak some of
them are well north of a hundred dollars
depending on the cut that you get
depending if it's wagyu or not wago you
know like
it it's crazy but this is what they want
like if you're an idiot and you're dumb
enough to go to salt based restaurant
you should pay
thousands of dollars for that
the steak should be 2
000 because you're already dumb enough
to go right like that's the marketing
meeting like when they talk to salt bay
they go listen these people are already
stupid enough to walk in the door of
this restaurant you've proved absolutely
nothing about your ability to do
anything other than like
let salt trickle down your [ __ ]
forearm onto a piece of meat so the fact
that people are going to this means
they're idiots and idiots and they're
rich enough and they'll pay any amount
of money so let's just start charging
850 dollars
for a stake
and why not
why not i'm for this in a big way
somebody tweeted it's cheaper to fly and
have food at salt bay's turkish
restaurant than to go to the london one
yeah the london one's very expensive
i love when you now by the way somebody
said that salt bae and i don't know if
this is true
is a very popular halloween costume
is this is it could this possibly be
true let's see here
i mean
let me hit news to see if it's like
i mean i'm not seeing anybody write
anything about it
supposedly
salt bay's hey i was uh
i'm an inspiration to children all over
the world has something to do with the
fact that people are dressing up as him
first of all kids don't want to be uh
restaurateurs
they want to be like firemen right they
want to be like like garbage men they
like things with trucks men
little girls want to be like princesses
and i'm not saying this is always the
case i don't want to
reinforce the gender binary but a lot of
people
the children don't want to they're not
like thinking clearly
you know what i mean like what kind of
children are an inspiration imagine if
you asked your son or daughter like what
do you want to be and they go well you
know what i really like this guy's salt
bae he doesn't really do anything and
everybody goes to his restaurants they
spend 900 on steak so i wish i could be
like him
because it's really spectacular like
your three-year-old tells you this maybe
they'll be terrifying yeah if your
three-year-old just looks you can go the
world is primarily spectacle
sope really exemplifies this wouldn't
you say you go what
kids want to be like spider-man yeah
when they grow up they don't want to be
a some freak
this is a guy by the way like you know
mario batali it came out that mario
batali had a rape room yes what do you
think's gonna come out of a salt bay
eventually
it's gonna come out that salt bay was
like a cannibal
who liked carving women up and and
eating them
where does he come from salt bath uh
turkey
interesting
salt bay well we wish him the best
he's a uh
he's a figure that uh nurse rat yeah i
mean
turkish chef yeah it's the power of
instagram good for him
good for him
he made a lot of money all you need is
one viral video on instagram that gets
people going
truly
all you need is one viral video just one
on instagram
and and you can hawk your products
to morons
who want to feel something before the
end
and that's what his restaurant's about
people in his restaurant they're just
like this with the phone they're like
look look where we are look at salt
people really have so little
uh going on in their life that it's
exciting
to them speaking of products boy do we
have a lot of them
where are they where are they at here we
go wake up thank you
where are these advertisements
we only use we only
advertise products on this show
that i have a personal
love for and relationship with i would
never in my life
and many of you know this about me all
the things that i've been involved with
subprime mortgages
office supplies
i have the highest standards of
integrity no one's standards of
integrity are harder than mine when it
comes to uh product placement and and
branding
um and so
every product here is something that i
am intimately acquainted with i've used
i love what is this this is better help
i mean i have i cannot say enough about
better help because
people need help
and the help that they're getting is
what
uh over the phone on the computer no
it's not
no it's not
what kind of help are we talking well
they're getting sub-par help
oh right yes right they're not using
better help that's for sure right see
how dumb he is he doesn't follow
anything
better help
is a
helpline but it's not a helpline it's
real therapists
that have been recruited
to help you deal with your problems
online
it's not like self-help
it's not a crisis line
these are intelligent people that want
to help you they're compassionate
intelligent
better h-e-l-p there's over a million
people that have taken charge of their
mental health with the help of an
experienced professional in fact so many
people have been using better health
they got to recruit additional
counselors in every one of the 50 states
you can log into your account anytime
and send a message to your counselor
you'll get timely and thoughtful
responses plus you can schedule weekly
video or phone sessions and you won't
ever have to sit in an uncomfortable
waiting room as with traditional therapy
go to betterhelp.com reviews and you can
read about all their reviews but if you
go to betterhelp.comtimd
well now we're talking
because what
then you're going to get
what do you get that's help and you join
over the million people who have taken
charge of their house help and tim dylan
show listers get 10 off their first
month are you kidding me that's pretty
good oh it's disgusting how how much you
people get
better help tim d
slash tim do you get 10 off your first
month at
do you know and i i i've told you this
i had a therapist
once
and the they're not a lot of them aren't
good
but the people that uh that use this
seem to be very happy with it
and that's beautiful to me
it's absolutely beautiful
because i feel that if i had a better
therapist i would have more
joy that's definitely true a hundred
percent yeah the podcast is sponsored by
better help and tinder and show
listeners get 10 off their first month
at betterhelp.com tim d i love cereal
it's one of my favorite things but
sometimes i say to myself jesus [ __ ]
christ it's [ __ ] sugar filled i'm
gonna kill myself and everyone i know
i'm such a sugar pig
oh man i love licking that sugar
it's just like sex you feel it all down
your throat that thick sugar [ __ ] i want
sugar in my [ __ ] face
i look and i feel when i eat sugar i
feel
happy but then sad and i and i sleep
sometimes i pull into a parking lot and
i sleep in the back seat of my car and i
go to sleep and if someone wakes me up i
say [ __ ] you
[ __ ] you i just start screaming and they
go do you want to make sure you're okay
and i'm like [ __ ] you
because i've had sugar sugar is very bad
the happiest people i know don't eat
sugar they just eat bone marrow they're
happier sugar is bad and it's october it
is so hard to not eat sugar in october
candy and halloween and pumpkin muffins
and apple tartlets and peach and pocket
pie
and you just lose your mind with the
sugar i mean you just i mean the other
day
i was eating a pumpkin
[ __ ] i was eating a a pumpkin
scone you know what hard one oh wow and
i was gnawing on it and and and someone
came up to me and they said does that
have sugar in it and i said you stupid
[ __ ] of course it does and they go are
there any sugar-free scones and you know
what i did i beat the living [ __ ] out of
them and it was a diabetic on dialysis
who was very weak but i attacked them
and they had they were older and every
time you hit them you could see their
blood clotting in real time they had
those they were like very frail in their
skin and i just started wailing on them
throwing hay makers you saw this blood
all over their but their eyes were like
sunk in
to their head like a demon and they were
just like i just wanted sugar and i say
no sugar sugar-free none but then i
remembered that i should have
[Laughter]
told them about magic spoon cereal
because in all actuality magic spoon is
sugar-free and that's what makes it good
so if you go to magicspoon.com tim dylan
get a custom bundle of cereal and try it
today and be sure to use our promo code
tim dillon they use high quality
sweeteners like monk fruit there's zero
grams of sugar 13 to 14 grams of protein
four net carbs in each serving only 140
calories are serving it's keto friendly
gluten free grain free soy free low carb
i'm telling you right now i think i
killed that person i'm not sure
but
i wish i told them about magic spoon
instead of physically assaulting them
because they were elderly and very sick
and that's where i sometimes regret
my actions do you know what i mean i
feel like you would have wouldn't have
done that if you had known that they
just brought back two super popular
flavors which ones did they bring back
cookies and cream and maple waffle
permanently here's let me tell you this
it could have gone one of two ways
because if i knew that i would have
either a not
done it at all or would have been so
excited i would have slit their throat
i don't know which way it would have
gone if i knew that yeah you know that's
the difficult thing
magicspoon.com tim dillon to grab a
custom bundle of cereal try today buy
the magic spoon folks you need to do it
everyone i know that's using magic spoon
is a beautiful person inside and out
magicspoon.com tim dillon use a promo
code tim dillon five dollars off you get
five dollars off
so we're excited about the many saints
of new york and we hope it's good we
know several people that will really
kill themselves if it's not good it's
true they're seeing it the first day it
comes out
uh people get really excited about these
things that's that's a big part of their
life
like i was in new york with people and
they went this is where they film the
sopranos like that's the entire way the
interface with the world is a show
and i love the sopranos i think it's
probably the greatest show ever made but
i haven't you know re-watched it 17
times
and i'm not going to see you know i
didn't buy my tickets six months ago to
see the many saints you knew it for the
first day but i understand that people
do it's like that irishman movie where
people were really overly invested
you know it's enough already to me i
think it's enough i think it's overkill
i haven't even seen the movie and i'm
going to go out and just say already
like i didn't need the prequel to tony
soprano's life i just didn't care it
didn't mean anything to me i thought it
was a brilliant piece of art we don't
need to make more of it than what it was
right we don't it's not a philosophy of
life i don't think or it shouldn't be
i don't think we need that i think we
need to just enjoy it for what it is
which is great art and then move away
step away
we don't need to get to sopranos
cookbook we don't need to you know talk
about feached la mana we don't need to
do any of that we don't need to start
going through
the episodes that have changed our lives
i think we just really need to move on
but again it's you know people are
putting a little too much
into it in my opinion but i could be
wrong maybe it's the greatest film
that's ever been made james gandolfini's
son is in it why i don't know
and philip seymour hoffman's son is now
in things licorice pizza what are we
going to thomas anderson why why are we
putting it they're [ __ ] to children
why in gods it makes me hate the legends
that died that we're giving your kid
aren't these people the same people that
talk about how unfair everything is and
inequality and they're always voting for
democrats because they're going to fix
the inequality and there's so many
concentrations of wealth and all they do
is is [ __ ] give dead people's kids
jobs that are already rich christ
almighty enough they're already [ __ ]
rich he's not a genius philip seymour
topman's sons not a genius his name is
[ __ ] cooper he's clearly not a genius
genius skips many generations okay like
all of them god forbid we get an actor
who's been in [ __ ] the grind for
years sleeping on a [ __ ] floor trying
to get this job who may be the next
philip seymour hoffman maybe let's do
that
okay what are you how do you cast things
now ancestry.com
this is absurd it's stupid and
disgusting all the things you people
pretend to care about you don't it's
just a cheap [ __ ] trick to get people
out to the [ __ ] movies well how about
make a good [ __ ] movie instead of
using these cheap [ __ ] tricks
okay
i have no beef with gandolfini's son and
i have no beef with
cooper hoffman or whatever
but jesus christ already why are we
doing this they're not the best
candidates it's absolutely impossible
that they are the best candidates for
the job
there's no [ __ ] way
they're gonna keep doing this
they're just gonna keep giving roles to
children whose parents are legends
who've died
here's what i love about stand-up comedy
i know i won't mention names there are
legends whose children do stand up
comedy no one cares about them and
that's so important
because it is kind of a little bit of a
meritocracy isn't it yeah isn't it
i mean so what's going on and i've had a
little i've been enough with paul thomas
anderson too you freak wait no he's the
genius who have i had enough with
moonrise kingdom oh wes anderson i've
had enough with him i've just had enough
with him and i like a lot of what he's
done
paul thomas anderson i like a lot i know
that's your favorite director yeah he's
great he is great wes anderson i've had
enough with you he's put chalamet in the
new one yeah i'm kind of sick of it
chalamet stop ruining everything you do
he really is man he's ruining everything
this is the new one it's like you know
it's bill murray francis mcdormand the
whole thing but then timothy is is kind
of the star of this one oh god get me
out of here please this life is it's
called the french dispatch here it is of
course it is you just look at look at
his face he's just that's good it's
called one you know what i call that one
black actor
that's what i call it
i don't call it the french dispatch i
call it more of the same
is free you know go go
i want christopher gas to cast a movie
with fred willard's son
you know
everybody's you know and this is
hollywood everybody's like no it's the
concentrations of wealth and
family money and
listen wes anderson's great and maybe
this movie will be good i'm i'm a little
sick of
chalamet
i'm just sick of it yeah can't we have
something else
can we have something else other than
this twink who doesn't age
this pixie who does not age that must
prance through every [ __ ] movie
that's ever been made
is there anything else that's all
is there anyone else that can do this
job
please
and not hansel and gretel elgort not him
either can we get someone else please
someone else other than timothy chalamet
what about cooper hoffman
what does cooper hoffman look like i'll
show you
this is uh that's him as a kid so here's
what he looks like in the movie right
here
he kind of looks like philip seymour
hoffman and boogie nights just kind of
the
so if this isn't offensive why am i
supposed to be offended that
uh like jamie dimon's kid has money
right so when somebody at goldman sachs
gives a job to their son why is that
supposed to offend me you frauds why is
that supposed to offend me if this
doesn't offend me or shouldn't it all
offend me
i guess technically yeah one of the kids
that got hard on snl's dad's like a
producer at essendon i don't really care
about that and i even tweeted like
enough ready because the kid's funny the
kid is funny and if i see these movies
and these guys are really good in it
i'll still say [ __ ] them because it
still should have went to you know one
of these other people i'd end up hating
but
one of the kids got snl i forget you
know one of those strange looking kids
from brooklyn that sketch group
and
i forget the name it's unimportant but
uh his dad's a producer on snl adam
sandler collab yeah we don't have to
name him yeah yeah and people people
were like all to twist it up about that
i'm like guys this is the way the world
works the guy with the dad gets the job
and the kid's funny and their sketch
group's funny i mean they probably hate
me or whatever you know it's like
logical and brilliant but
um
i just don't care
like if i i'm just saying let's not care
at all
like don't [ __ ] ever come to me and
start talking about like finance
families then
stop with this [ __ ] just cut it out
immediately if you're gonna do this and
hollywood seems like they're gonna do
this if we're just going to as a as a
gimmick
give roles to dead people's kids then i
don't want to hear [ __ ]
about [ __ ]
the presidency of george w bush
remember that when bush was the thing
that was an entire narrative of like how
would you let this god right i'm sure
this guy's a nice guy michael gandolfini
i'm sure he's lovely i don't know like a
nice kid i don't know i don't care
take your money and get out of here
can anyone take their goddamn money and
leave please
is anything ever enough
for christ
anything
how many generate like what let it go
we didn't need this [ __ ] movie
the many saints in new york
wow what
we didn't need it yeah we didn't need el
camino either the breaking bad one with
jesse pink we did not need that i didn't
even i didn't even dignify that but with
even like
letting it hold any space in my head we
do not need that who's that actor uh
aaron paul we do not need more of him
we do not need that we do not need
labrea and then one of the kids in
library i think is a sweet kid but you
you have to be homeless and the show has
to be canceled
sorry
the jack kid oh jack martin yeah he's a
nice kid i've met him you know he's an
actor in l.a but
he's not a bad actor probably but the
show is atrocious and i believe it
should be canceled and that he should
have to work at like astro burger for a
year to pay for what he's done yeah
to just flip a few
put a few
put a mayo in a bun
make a nice burger to pay for what
you've done to us with this show
where people fall in a hole
i
you know
and why should he have a chance let
somebody let some some dead guys kid do
it
why have a new actor do it let's have a
debt let's have someone who died let's
have their kid do it
that's all
that seems to make sense you know
one exception is michael k williams son
michael k williams i don't know if he
has a son but maybe if he has a son he
could do something okay that's my one
exception
oh yeah that would be cool that might be
cool that's one exception
it rarely doesn't skip a generation you
have like larry mcmurtry james mcmurtry
it's hard to think about listen
princess diana
died right
and what's her son doing over here
wasting everyone's goddamn time
him and his wife are running around
spending millions of dollars on security
okay
i don't know what they're afraid they're
afraid that someone's gonna come near
them and be racist
so they have to spend millions and
millions of dollars going to new york
city hotel she you know she spent 75k on
the on the baby shower at the
presidential suite at the mark you're
sitting there eating caviar and they are
running around here so i just just
stopped talking about fairness and
inequality and the death tax and all
this [ __ ] like
stop this please stop it please
i'm i'm i'm i'm i'm just uh you know
maybe they're good maybe maybe i'll see
the many saints of newark
but again the gay storyline shocked me
it stunned me
i was not prepared for it it was very
interesting there's a scene in the thing
where tony is just getting
i mean it's brutal and he's screaming oh
oh
oh [ __ ]
and you know what he's screaming as he's
getting [ __ ] there is no god he's
going there is no [ __ ] god there is
no god i hate god and i just go you know
it's too much
timberlandcomedy.com live tickets uh uh
we're on tour i i just shut up and go
into the shows are known i don't even
care anymore i have to go to the ontario
improv ontario california is one of the
biggest dumps in america but the crowds
are [ __ ] phenomenal because they have
nothing to live for
um
you know when does this come out uh
tomorrow the saturday yeah it's over by
the time this comes out it's over go to
milwaukee wisconsin get tickets folks
i'll be the next weekend spokane
washington seattle washington we're
there at the end of the month portland
oregon indianapolis morgantown west
virginia pittsburgh pennsylvania
washington d.c new york atlantic city
atlantic city rochester
and
many more iowa city madison louisville
los angeles bakersfield i do want to
maybe say something about this iowa city
thing okay but we don't have the time
it's 3 57. we have like three minutes if
you want it's not enough
what i'm going to say is i'm going to
discuss it on the patreon the people
that run the theater in iowa city
sent out some type of email apologizing
for booking me because some members of
their like uh corn community were
offended by things i had said of course
they're not canceling the show because
they want money correct they're
hypocrites
and they sent out an email um you know
and they said that i had like questioned
the vaccine or something
i'm vaccinated i never said don't get
the vaccine i told people to make their
own choices i've also said the vaccine's
not working as well as everybody thought
it you know
would and by the way
that is something that i believe pfizer
would agree with i mean this is
legitimately crazy
um i've said people should make their
own decisions about that and about
everything about voting about everything
i don't care what you do
um there's good reasons i'm sure that
people have for not taking the vaccine
and then there's good reasons that
people have for taking it i don't know
your health and your medical it's not my
[ __ ] problem i'm not your doctor um
and then he also said that i said
something racist about black lives
matter i believe i suggested that the
person
who
was running black ice matter should not
have spent
millions of dollars buying four houses i
said that tamir rice's mother said we
didn't see any of the money maybe she's
a racist too i don't know i guess
everyone's a racist um but this theater
of you know who these people are in iowa
i mean they they're the whitest uh
biggest [ __ ] in the world who are
pseudo-intellectuals worthless people
they live in iowa they're in the art
scene and they live in iowa that's how
seriously they take doing things um and
their embarrassments their
embarrassments to life these people
let's be very honest they're
embarrassing their embarrassments
and they send out an article because
some fat chick in the theater program
didn't like something i said well how
about moving out of iowa and trying to
make it for real okay dummy move to new
york move to la and try to get on la
brea or whatever the hell you want to do
but you send an email out and you didn't
handle the shows i don't know what i'm
going to do i'm looking for other venues
i'm angry about this i'm not happy about
it
um
they're like treating me like it's weird
to send an email out and be like uh he's
questioned the response to the pandemic
i'm like i didn't do that i don't even
know what the [ __ ] that means
um this is weak it's truly weak that
they did this i'm unhappy about it
they're slimy
serpent-like
uh behavior to do this to send an email
out on this low
on the side and then you look for the
comments where are all these guys i
can't find anything where are all these
comments on social media
no one's mad where is everyone that's so
angry about this in your pretend world
in their inbox shut up
iowa give me a break please
you're lucky i'm going there we should
use it as a nuclear testing facility
the iowa democratic primary all these
people care about is they have the iowa
caucus where all these idiots every year
they get a bunch of morons in a house
and the democrats go in there and people
are like well i'm concerned about trade
and my daughter's non-binary and then
you have to pretend that these [ __ ]
people matter these corn-fed slobs no
one gives a [ __ ] shut the [ __ ] up and we
have to pretend that they matter because
of this dumb electoral college or
whatever and i think the electoral
college is good because you do need
some proportional representation i'm not
trying to tell people in these small
states what to do but the idea that
we're supposed to care about these
[ __ ] monsters is just not true and
that's
they derive their sense of like
political importance from the iowa
caucus
where they all have to convince each
other it's not even a secret about they
don't have to convince each other and
like they'll have to debate and
somebody's like pete but judge
is in the diner and he saw me and he
said that he was gonna
be fair to the little babies that are
different
it's like all right you shut the [ __ ] up
so i'm you know i'm in a one-sided war
with this dumb theater that just sent an
email but of course they don't want to
cancel the show because they need they
need uh money cause tickets are selling
yeah tickets are selling and they need
uh money to pay their 400 a month
mortgage or something
you know
whatever anyway
i'll be
i'll be in malibu ho
good night